okay it's been a while but I'm back I've
been
out of town for the last three weeks
four weeks most of April I was in
California between San Francisco LA Palm
Springs Newport Beach and then I was in
st. Louis for the last week got back
last evening and now I'm playing blitz
I'm chess calm it's a weekly arena Kings
tournament starts in just about three
minutes I think about two minutes and
about 15 seconds cool I'm gonna tweet
that I'm streaming and I have a strange
window configuration where
I don't know if I can tweet without like
actually showing the tweets
apologize for this but I'm just gonna go
to my Twitter real quick and make a
tweets I'm sure the thing is a little
messed up here but what should I say
streaming Marina Kings
let's tournament on Escom last time I
just said at chess and it was like some
random Twitter account but their their
account is chess comm watch live my
twitch name I am rosin here
streaming for the next two hours cool
and we will tweet any hashtag any
hashtags are people in the chat people
are in the chat cool I'm not going to
leave a hashtag we're just going to
tweet this tweet a sense
minimize that
and let me go back to my configuration
[Music]
okay yeah last time I screamed this
tournament I just had the board and my
logo and people couldn't see the
standings so now at least people can see
like the standings and the time left so
hopefully it's a more enjoyable watching
experience we have just about 30 seconds
until starts I see people are saying
hello hello GTX hello the jeff boy the
chess jeff boy no the the chess boy Jeff
I'm slightly just dyslexic today so it's
hard to uh to read stuff Ariel was token
hello was taken wow I'm very bad at
reading today Nathan F welcome back axe
villager good to see you yeah we have 10
seconds hopefully I can play better
chess and my reading abilities but we'll
see I've been watching a lot of chess so
hopefully that has some shows in some
way I'll play a London
click with my comfort zone
some symptoms of setup start with 92
Bishop g3 we're going to sum a mine
beep it should be 5 okay so we have this
line
still like lesser known than the
mainline Bishop d3 but there should be
five as uh as a move that kind of throws
people off
threat is very simple just to take the
night's which he induces me to play and
now the threat is both queen takes you
six in Queen egg three or even Bishop
take T six and then Queen a3 a lot of
people miss sex but he okay he knows
what he's doing
um okay so we have some positional game
I'll try and go after the C pawn will
start with Queen a3 might be three and
rook c1 ideas I probably want a castle
even though he kind of gave me the H
file a5 is a decent move I'm gonna play
this move like a knight in c5 thanks
Nathan for the ten bits
I'm going to try my best not to look at
the Chapas this tournament but it might
be difficult but we'll see
do I put on c1 or do I play 95 first
play 95 first why not b6 is attacked
Brooke c1 will come very soon
Brooke a c1 makes more sense
maybe slow play like Roxy - Rick fc-1
I'm restricting you wants to play 96
maybe I can play night CD 3
now I'm just targeting c6 and you can't
play Bishop d7 because 97
maybe he'll play rock a6 but then on top
up on the C file
f6 is coming okay
that's okay my Knights defended by my
queen rook c1 will still come I see 5 on
the horizon
maybe Queen e7 ideas too when he seven
would hang the knight so there has to be
a good reason for that
I'm gonna try my best to manage my time
like that's one of the most important
things
look see one why not
I'd see five rook c5 next or queen e7
here 27 wait rook takes c6 is also a
move Queen d6 is a move I've so many
juicy looking moves 26
this pawn is so weak
I could've played when I see if I was
also move
Oh many great options you might play
Knight d5 here and then I can take on c6
just went upon
okay he's attacking the night
but his night is also hanging
[Music]
what to do
do this
k7
Brook be sick so he just flung his
Knights
he forgot it was hanging okay next game
no time to waste
oh I'm playing George Mayer let's play
another London
you're gonna go go way back we first
play that the Final Four of college
chess he was playing for the Webster
team I was playing for the University of
Illinois team he's playing some line I
thought this is pleasant for whites
like if he ever takes on g3 I get some
h-file action meanwhile I'll just Castle
queenside and then always clicking b1
ship t3 okay so playing the opening
pretty quickly boo he castles so it's
going to be a shark game but what do I
do here d5 at some point
know what to do maybe bring my night to
f4
see what he's going to do with his night
I'd be happy if he takes on g3
he's thinking that's good he's probably
going to go for something like c5 or d5
or beef I'd like one of these pawn
breaks
I have my own plans JCS with the rosin
smash emoji by the way if people have
emoji or emote suggestions non emoji
emote suggestions let me know because I
became a twitch partner a couple of
weeks ago and now I have a lot more
emote options so yeah let me know if you
guys have any emotes that you
desperately want
he plays c5 looks reasonable still going
to go for 9 F for no time to waste not
six interesting maybe Bishop no this
should eat you probably not good could
trade like Bishop h4
hmmm d5s a move
five tick tick tick probably not good
enough like King a one because I don't
know what else to do it's just a waiting
move my king is slightly safer on a one
ally shouldn't have taken so much time
to do that
hello super dank fire thanks for
watching
okay no more looking at the chat it was
seriously so he's also waiting kind of a
waiting game I'm gonna play Bishop e2 I
want him to commit this night that was
another reason I played King a1 so
there's no more pain on the diagonal um
so if he plays Bishop b4 I have like
queen c3 or something I also might want
to play d5 because now my rook is i
Rick's actually on the same file as his
Queen now there's some x-ray vision like
this
uh what to do Knight g5 maybe my g5 I'm
attacking this twice so fork ideas also
taking that okay he plays a reasonable
move now I want to play my H pawn push
Harry I think Simon Williams is playing
this tournament but I don't know
[Music]
regardless I'm inspired by him h4
might be hanging something who he plays
h6 so quickly
likely h5o him somehow
mmm doesn't quite work okay I'll move
back
I don't want to get into the time
scramble because I'm I got a new laptop
and the trackpad is slightly weird on
this laptop I'm not as fast as it as
with my old my old trackpad which has a
bit unfortunate
I played d5
d5 tick ticks on a sack I could
open files either this is critical
pick
how much time
yeah I'm gonna play this move because I
have to do something
oh he just takes my sack
I feel like sacking maybe not
objectively good but at least I got d5
in this could go bad very quickly but
okay there's some attack there's some
compensation he might play Bishop f6
which could be troublesome
but if he plays five then the center
closes down
he's thinking that's good
eh one lyric h1r at age five and then
target age six
so keep remove that
also if you play z5 he gives me that 5
square which I don't know it's useful in
any way I'll play rook h1 because if you
take some d5 I take on h5
okay maybe hmm do Queeny for maybe
defend
maybe rock h3r up g3 ideas
mmm
you want some play Bishop f6
okay I have to play an awkward move like
this and then queen up three so Bishop
f6 Queen up three it's gonna be a time
scramble h4 interesting what is this
note later okay efore
a Bishop III coming III maybe let's open
the G file
I'm gonna be really slow with this
trap b5 coming yes I got e5 and e6 maybe
you
take pawns
you
no I got
hey I won a game yay with three seconds
left
my I'm I'm sweating but okay that was
worth it
pay two for two I'm in first place
I think I'm playing a 1900
but now I'm shaking I was intense let's
play solid chess here I'm gonna play d5
we'll just play a qgt have to calm down
drink some tea early I have tea
I do here 97
um I forgot this line take
1995
that's something like slow position may
be quite slightly better
but he's 1900 I just have to play quick
that wasn't okay move maybe I'll play
this there should be seven
pointed ryos
maybe like take on c3 and 94 looks
Pleasant so he wants to win ce7
I could play this we're gonna get some
like route to the equal position or
maybe I cannot play him
as I have 94 coming if I get the bishop
hair life will be good
got 94
I'm off I'll take on g3 right away
because my nice just a monster but maybe
I will take take his rooks are good I
play Bishop a6
when material
oh I'll let him calculate this rook d2
now rip d2 I just take on d2
it should take a 694 back and come
winning the exchange
ninety-seven counter-attack that should
not do anything to harmful maybe I take
on g3 first
click on g3 take on g3 work th ER
should be just winning
Brook TX we can trade
pawn for the exchange that we can trade
down a little bits and other up to d8
c4b pawn and maybe I'll win his a pawn
rook a five kind of annoying play this
I just want to play like g6 not get back
mated and then eventually rip d2
let's hold onto a pond for a bit longer
now Rick t2 or rook see to Roxy to
no I'll just improve he's kind of stuck
okay I'm gonna play rook d2 and then
then Roxy - and then he won't have
Bishop c66 and end well I want it win f2
without him hanging onto g2 important
detail
maybe he'll play Bishop f1 also slightly
annoying
he's gonna take on a seven take on f2
Bishop f1 or he plays Bishop c6
oh wait no the bishop wasn't oh my gosh
why did I I was imagining the rook was
on a seven I was so bad
it was just a brain fart
well this is not good
to play dirty to win this now
I got way too comfortable there
how did that happen
yes that's a good thing about being up
the exchange like that wasn't even on
plunger that was just a poor life
decision
mm okay let's not get invaded maybe I
can meet him somehow
I grew up t7 f5
mmm might be tricky though
they work t5
I want to avoid any sort of like serious
time trouble I have to figure out how to
make progress so
making to be southern it's difficult
maybe there's some trap where I can meet
him
sure I don't get meted myself
mate with rip t6
a rook now
to do
I'm gonna lock the king to be seven
with what else
then maybe I win the a pond
you
I don't want to calculate
hey I queen with check yes calculation
paid off
but am i winning this
time somehow
okay now I'm winning he should have
played King f8
hey I've won all my games so far this is
dirty but at least the result is good
hey that wasn't a dirty flag that was
just a dirty calculation I'm gonna play
d4
I'll stick with London have I've had
pretty good success so far I feel like
I've played this guy before and it's
possible
I don't think Bishop alpha is the most
precise move
I hold on to the pond
it should be 5 in 9 ft for ideas they
for
we need to learn how to use a mouse
because this trackpad just feels so
different
maybe I can play 94 immediately
white self upon and take care bill up
upon he's going to play 94 though
mm okay you place 94 I'll take it I just
want to hold on to the pond
castle
the position play Queen d2 d1 next
yeah I'll probably start using my
logitech gaming mouse cuz i bought it
last month but just didn't start using
it
um a little bit concerned about g5s5 but
I think it's okay supply pressure in the
center
Brook fd1 yeah sure
94 maybe
with a trade is now I get the pawn on d4
I have some majority Bishop c7 wins
another pawn
I take with Bishop upon
bishop because now a five is hanging and
I'll have three connected passers just
losing all his pawns but he's going to
attack on the Kings side so I have to be
careful still
it's actually a short position
I do have to be very careful they
bishops III
I was more scared of f3 I think this is
okay I might have rookie one actually
rookie one
Bishop g5
idiots not completely solved
yeah
lay this I'll play like rookie - and
then rook a e1 or something
or I could just take on III have so many
pawns for the exchange
he's still going to try and attack
I can do this preen trade
so much with his rook
is now Ricky one
wait a minutes or do I push pons first a
five
probably just start pushing
you
as Kings going to come in
that's okay though
upon b6
there let's play Bishop d6
not the best technique actually this is
tricky okay now I can check in Bishop b6
this is good
you might take on be no he can't take on
b6 I can take with a pond that's nice
okay this is technically winning now
it's more technically winning bring the
King to F to put the rook on e4 keep
everything defended
and then start pushing just up to pawns
37 seconds should be enough time
was not the best decision at all when
these pawns we skate to take with King
please know he takes with rook okay
still winning cut the King off we'll get
some Lucena position
or we'll just start pushing pawns
oh he's gonna defend from behind us so
tricky
you
26 seconds
be enough time
is this a theoretical draw it might be
but
defenders with the time situation
the King on at six
mm that's annoying
you
and now it should just be Lucena
position
I mean to redo that
okay keep moving up
wait how do I win this they mess up
oh my gosh though it should still be
winning the King on g8
so sir
you
I have to dirty Fagin again
this too many opponents so far
oh my gosh it still mates wait what no
why did I play rookie six I was such a
poor or hit time to move but I was gonna
[ __ ] him because his king was awkward but
least I still haven't lost Jets but that
was unnecessary okay
I can't I can't get tilted from one game
I was really unfortunate I probably had
King g8 at some point there
so unfortunate hey this guy's thinking
I was playing Lila chess other day and
she was playing this but she played some
other line not rookie one
and now we have some mainline and play a
six I'd c3 Queen d6 the best move for
white is a three to stop might be four
but we'll see if he does that no he does
okay there's my Knights slightly
misplaced on c6 but not too bad I'll
just bring my rook soon start with rook
ft8
exceeds
maybe I'll go for b4 I'm with before it
allows like Knights
a42 c5c threatening
I'd be threatening something here
you
[Music]
each three
he's not desirable usually like white
wants to play cheese or black wants to
play g6 but this looks okay I have Queen
d5
maybe some tension or x-ray vision
against the Jeep on I'm threatening
night 84 I think
that easy to stop
he's going for some counter-attack so if
I take on d4 Bishop to h6 Knight f5
could be nice
I'll have a five immediately just win a
piece
jisuk stick tape is scary
mmm
I don't know
I took t4
do this seems simpler
this bishop queen camo is as nice
I'm in 15th place wait what
I won so many games maybe not quickly
enough
did lose my streak
it's a long tournament lot can happen
wait what what I didn't even
how did that even happen I didn't even
click and drag
did I
maybe I did I don't know
- plane out of five this has happened
before - because maybe click-click was
turned on
a
fortunate I mean obviously I have to
play another five there
it's gonna put me on tilts I'm playing
the chess couch let's try and be him
quickly
yeah I mean I would like to blame chess
comm for that Mouse lip but I don't know
I just have to play myself
okay new game now the position was going
to be good after nine five to
new game okay double fianchetto I can
put the bishop on h3 maybe sometimes
black lights the Castle queenside in
this line the bishop is effective
g4 pops out
lady three first under - bishop
I'm in I'm in 21st place there's a lot
of people playing guess
Queen f3
now his queen is tied down to this pawn
by 94
it could allow it
so I have to allow it mighty for I'll
play queen d1
I think the argument is that his king
will be less safe than my king hopefully
mmm he wants to Castle queenside
Bishop f5 maybe a four let's trying to
scourge him from castling queenside
okay well now it probably doesn't make
sense for him to Castle queenside but
this pawn on e5
might still do it
of c3 I don't want to trade please
or Bishop d4 I could play c3 like Bishop
e3
see an interesting line but if Bishop c5
I can take on e6
via trade Bo
empty for in some lines whoa let's play
Trixie one threatening c3
you want to play 94
I guess I could take on e6
if he takes honey one I might be down
the exchange
economy one maybe Bishop d5
we'll be comp
I take on c5 and then take on f6 because
that looks really fun
I should win a six
it's probably not necessary I'm gonna
stay safe do that
respond to spruce egg audre does stream
but not frequently don't think he's
streamed in a while
please let's move taxi five
Queen h6 idea is to
ooh now I'm threatening c3 and I take g6
I think he's losing something
okay well I'm chopping the bishop
oh yes bishop take d3 then rip d2
so I'm winning a piece
just gotta manage my time
you
when this will win more stuff
everything's falling for black when this
guy OB sevens not hanging could play f3
should be too simple move he's going to
play e5 in the night of five
have some sort of threats
this is winning something because King
f8 Bishop a3
some window actually
the meaning should be meeting somehow
I mean it's a windmill I can take his
pawns on the seventh and then figure out
what to do
can take on e5 note let's not take on e5
right away
what's the best option
[Music]
wait I can't use too much time let's
just take that pawn
I still have some mating attack
analysis on time
bishop
you
I'm trying to promote
and this and this
okay mates I want a game okay back to
tournaments do I lose two in a row I
guess I know I drew and then lost okay
so now I have a streak again I think the
key with this sort of tournament is to
keep a streak let's play a perk
what's sharp line can i play against the
perc id7 is weird
let's play f4 on the be super sharp
so he wants to play some old Indian
setup
so I think this is one of the best
responses
can take with Queen maybe as he doesn't
have 96
they for sooner rather than later
Knight f6 could run into Bishop g5 d5
unexpected he wants to play Bishop c5
but that's okay I've queen e4 check
this is just a bad this is petal pain
for black this is not secret prep this
is just bad opening I could take on g7
to
choices choices second g7 he probably
has to play Queen f6 and then we'll
trade Queens I'll be up a couple pawns
oh I've secret prop against a perk
that's true like Indy one threatening
rookie one
open file
or the rook wants to be so now I've
Queen a 6i over p1 check King d8 and
maybe I still trade Queens whoa he's
walking to rook e1
[Music]
he has 94 I could just take his rook do
most uh okay he wants to get some weird
counterplay
- - some lines tick-tick-tick
relatively straightforward if 94 I take
only forth and take on eight shades I
think
9f2 is a bit unpleasant
and now I'm threatening to take our g8
I'm currently up a rook no I'm I'm up a
a minor piece which is nice
I'm still up a minor piece I have ninety
two two of consolidates also Queen g5
click wing g5 first
when coin f1 probably doesn't do too
much but I'll stop it anyway my t2 will
come next
and maybe he'll resign
or maybe he'll play on yeah we can trade
Queens just up a piece here
I D for coming
yeah to shower I do have a what does
that emote with twitch votes I do have a
twitch partnership now
which hasn't really changed much I don't
think apart from more emotes I do have a
Fabiano emotes I need to make a Sam
Shanklin to emote though her new US
Champion
h3
I do a 45
for
you
so I mean I don't know what these
numbers mean what does 12 and 30 mean
no I hung a piece I was so perplexed by
these random numbers I just dropped a
piece
well I'm up am i up upon I'm up one part
okay semester wing
I'm so yeah I've made some very careless
blunders today I also be George minor so
today's a weird day
I would remove seat 84 let's win upon
least I simplified
by hanging a piece play b5 a six
yes I could pre-move the rest of the
moves
you
okay
I still don't know what these numbers
are I'm playing creeks or though
Bacoor my arch-nemesis
got the better of me last tournament
we'll see what happens this time
going for this this Shabalala Shibata
has beat me in the sign twice in
tournaments not the most pleasant
experience
they can castle
one day I'll play c5 maybe right now
it can start with rookie Yates the f8
square can be used for a night or a
bishop depending okay he wants to kill
me
that was probably a good move
like c5 maybe IC 5ad off this Bishop
he's going to play f6 I can take take
[Music]
I don't know what's going on doesn't
look that great though
if I lose I'll lose quickly that's I
guess comforting
c-pawn interesting
[Music]
we should before
I don't know actually take tick I don't
take
I'll play Bishop before
if he takes on g7 his pawn kind of acts
as a shield for my king
oh he just wants to meet me after play
g6
okay please don't make me I mean I have
bishop f8 if I need it
the King h8 could move to start with
you
oh he wants to meet me on each Saturn
that's a good move
what else to do I have to play h5
wait this is bad
this is a really bad King age it was
terrible maybe there wasn't much better
but this is not what I wanted
you
okay h5 don't kill me
maybe I got some weird counterplay like
it plays g4 I play d4 c5 stuff
now he wants to make me
this is so so bad
Quinn deep something
I want to play queen g4 it's not going
to end well
it's going to play rookie three that I
can take
hmm still just losing it
okay we'll see
I cannot from a draw I'm so long time to
even if I somehow to survive I'm just
gonna flag in g4 okay
[Music]
you
and what to do this move
you can take a guess
and then this
okay good game that was really bad I
need to look up that opening
next game
and that f5 move I probably should have
played g6 sooner dick [ __ ] big Bigfoot I
know how I had trouble pronouncing that
we're gonna play some chess
my own 29 place is that what that number
means
and I see six air
I'm in 29th place ouch that hurts
the streak
by age 5
the winsome quick games Bishop c5
in 94
mm he wants
trade
I guess I have to trade
or do I take take take take
so I do
it's awful I wanted though we're going
trade everything and grind him down
this endgame my pawn structure is
slightly worse but I'm gonna trade more
[Music]
in d7 will come oh I just need to be
ahead of streamers interesting well 30th
place is really bad
but still a long tournament I guess
last time I've had a very slow start at
night at the massive street towards end
you
I just have to play quickly too
again with the mouse ups I meant to play
king c6
about the end of the world though like
that previous game hyung made in one
so maybe there's some plan like f5
rookie for than c4
I play this position
the move I want to play to fix his pawn
in the dark square
let's move first
you
building up some pressure
you
if you play see for himself and
I can do this and then this
looking idea
where he is Bishop III there
should be three maybe I can't do that
could I have to move back what else to
do
and maybe I should have played c4 first
octi for doesn't do anything rook t4
hangs a rook
let's do this let's put the bishop on d4
my play Bishop III
take
and yes check
licking d5
now if he takes and plays f3 I've rookie
too
also up a ton of time
maybe I'll meet him Brooksie threes mate
besides
keep on ending winning
not
I just have to dirty flag him
or I cannot play him
looks like he's getting outplayed he got
three his pawns are weak
time to start taking pawns take take
we'll play rookie seven or that move for
counter play
upon
you
[Music]
work right because I queen first
you
wait a minute there there there there
there
no miscalculation I have to check and
somehow grind this down I was really bad
doesn't take though that's weird
you should have taken
our witness
and you just misplayed that
you
oh it's still a draw technically but
I'll dirty flagon
I'm sorry Bigfoot's
okay not a great game but what to do
29 place
your isn't expected yeah that's because
I'm screaming on chest comm there's
there's always less views from history
my chest calm because I don't think they
have the tools yet that are promoting
streams like if someone's observing my
game on chest comm it's not like
auto-detected like lightly chess I don't
think unless like there's some way
something I'm not aware of
I can take right wait what's this line
let's take
I'm playing a GM I didn't even realize
that maybe I shouldn't take them for
granted
5.95 going for some tacking ideas
we're trading a lot of things
is this is gonna be gonna be necessary
to play quickly because this could be a
long grind
t3
the technology is not there yet
[Music]
bg4
looks Pleasant pieces are doing stuff
see too
I like this position
have I setup streaming on me chess
accounts uh no I think they change it
where you can just set up a streaming
account like anyone can you just go to
their streamers page like just Google
Beach s streaming and to be the first
results
I can I take a bunch of things and wind
stuff
this looks Pleasant
I think he has to take with Queen but
I'm I'm gonna win the d5 Fon
good luck defending that's his Bishop e6
let's torture him
take this if rip da they take on e6
just up upon London success
bo fights business
guy
you
improve the King
keep the time advantage to
these sort of situations
place ice
now three why not
you
is being interesting
do this advance pawns maybe create a
passer on the queenside
well now b7 is so sad for him
what to do
I would like to paralyze him
play b5
or first
so many options
kingi to
so the c-pawn can be defended in some
lines
g4 okay
you
take
this move may be all made him
G for king of for King G to
you
I'm just going to push keep pushing
passes why not
in the Czech
you
as a matter of technique
meek has not been that great today but
it should be before
you
not super impressive
ah not impressive at all I'm still
winning though had a similar ending like
this earlier
you
there we go
okay new game
Rick of to maybe I'll come back I'm
still in 30th place
would be 35
and win some quick game
efore
d-4s aligned
slime I think I take on e4
well since I looked at this
maybe queen I think we know five
should really review this stuff
someday I just beat number one interest
extreme feeling
Bishop e7 I'm sacking upon but if he
takes on g7 I'll Castle queenside
let's keep Queens on the board
position
you
not even halfway done with the
tournament I have a lot of catching up
to do
32nd place
I still don't know how the point-scoring
works I was looking at the chest comm
article on this tournament and it
doesn't explain how the scoring system
works like how does a streak affect your
score
it says 37 points I assume I have 20
points I'm in 32nd place
if anyone can explain to me in the chat
that would be nice
now the two bishops are going to be very
very strong
fifty-five maybe
you
a bishop on c4 someday I'll go for like
a 5 P 4
also double up in the D file
wrists when is to point second witness
three in a row is three points so do you
keep getting more points of longer your
streak
is that how it works
wait am i winning something yes we can
trade
hmm
you
I'll go for this
you
maybe this isn't the best option
with night that's annoying if he takes
with Bishop I'm I'm okay with this
bending some trick
yeah I trail off the bishop here because
now his pawns are fixed on dark squares
Bishop e5
hooking some
I was going to provoke f4 there
for
risky
you
it's gonna take work to win this
you
not exactly what I wanted another long
grinding game I'm winning c3 maybe
Bishop t2 or that
oh I can activate my king
all those pawns are weak
I'll start playing d5
do this
we'll trim off these pawns
and then someday I should have worked
III
you
time Oh badly
you
let's do this
you
okay
hey it's mates get to play King a for it
but it would still be winning I think I
let's play E for this game
Sharper play some close Sicilian
there should be five
people are explaining so loss zero draws
one when is what
when is 20 seconds
still confused
- +4
but what is this sign I think he's
falling into some trap
he's falling into this trap I showed
this in the st. Louis Chess Club YouTube
video it's really funny line because
White's down a piece but black has no
defense in this position his rookie one
I'm threatening the bishop and the
Knights too many pins
well it's not nicely
I had this against Vanessa West at the
US Open in 2015 or 2014 I think 2015
you
the 2014 I forgets and she played nyla
for I played Bishop Bishop e5 we're just
following the same game
then this
after King of seven I can take care
and then I think Queenie for and Queen
jp-7 I were just following the same name
I showed this exact game in the st.
Louis chess club YouTube lecture such a
nice slide
um and then there's some ideas of I just
meeting the king I'm thinking so awkward
rook b8
to think I can play Queen c64 Queen a6
and Queen we can see six followed by b3
looks attractive actually
be
you
I still have Queenie for it too
for
I might repeat No
okay four
let's play a four just make black suffer
so hard for black to develop I have I
have like two pawns for the exchange I
mean another pawn whenever I want
I do forget what happened in the actual
game that I showed
Barisan because it was a games you
should know by heart lecture
where's the meat bin c5 king of seven
I could just take on a six to
like a free pond
26 okay
yeah this is good enough III
the pons Fischbach for is a track g5
logical move I'll play your plate should
be five first
I love the rook
to
like the the black rooks can't activate
because I control the EH squaring like
this Bishop is such a such a good piece
Bishop a5 maybe coming
let's play rookie six first
Bishop a5
okay I have a streak of four I am in
20th place I guess
I still don't know like how many points
I need to catch up confusing hopefully
not too many
it looks like I'm in I'm 12 points
behind the lead
okay let's find him so he likes me in a
Missoula
III okay
the slime
- okay
not too much about this line
remember there's some nice Adams games
whatever this is
you
I'm gonna play the side Yuna it's a
weird idea but it's suffering the night
to c7 and ei and d6
I'm that's what you need in blitz just
simple straightforward ideas Oh F or
that's a strong idea - oops
instead of annoying
it could take
okay I guess I'll take
you
not what I wanted
this is not pleasant
you
I have to play a really depressing move
here maybe I can play Knight c4 though
let's play Knight c4 but thread this to
play Knight g4 or 93 that somehow it
works
hopefully it does because I'm not
calculating May just plain anaphora and
I'm in trouble
yeah
maybe six perhaps it's actually
interesting looks playable threatening
to take any five maybe nine a four is
probably a decent move
we need science
I want to play rook to you at some
points
you
three
irritating
time management okay not eh6 when you
move
you
you
you
he's playing well
my Queens just getting trapped
Oh to do
design
well maybe I can play on maybe I've made
c4
I've
that's just losing
I'm playing on because okay maybe
there's some plates I should just resign
and play a new game but
before
you
smooth
you
five yellow
t-55
in g6 backing the lights
let's go move
you
later smooth
you
what's going on here taketake I'm losing
uh I'm losing on time I should say but
both his Knights are hanging
d5
we'll be six five years
but you found some good news this game
let's move
just resign where's the resign button
here it is okay next game
Fabian easy
by London
you
so more than halfway through the
tournament I'm in 21st place I guess
things could change quickly if like if I
do get a streak but it's been rough so
far lost a lot of games
I did break 2400 though so that's
something
by c5 or c4 at some queenside play
a bishop each - why not
someday I'll play b5 like right now
induce some weaknesses
Bishop d3
a very positional game
to be do
you
maybe I'm trapping something or winning
something it should be seven coming or
he just hangs his rook that's nice
see 6 is still very weak
you
you
this is just such a good position going
for work a seven
he just swung f7 Chang's a rook she
hangs everything blacks position just
falls apart good game
how does it feel good London I'm playing
Creek Oregon let's play e4
I've only played London against creeks
or
this'll be new
I don't want to go into a birthing
actually don't know how to play this
line I'll treat it like an Italian
I really don't know what I'm doing maybe
h3
laughs 193
you
yeah d5 we need to
you
haven't played these structures in a
while
the Bishop Don let's play before and
then Bishop b3
a little bit concerning my play metaphor
at some points
I'd already be thinking about 9s floor
probably should castle that doesn't
really solve things
you
and what else to do if you plays on the
floor I might have to play Queen c2
bit shaky
I'm slightly worse but holding on
you
maybe Bishop III at some points
you
Bishop III
[Music]
you
you
rook t1 at some points boo he's going
for positional play
I'm okay with the Queen trade in trade
more stuff I'll have these double e
pawns but his mic might get stuck if he
takes on you three
he's gonna play Nightbeat to know maybe
to Bishop III
what is he doing oh he wants to
late-night c4
I can take on e5 wait take you five take
b3 type III doesn't work if my t - maybe
hmm
we might have five as well
five
when ig5
as if he takes on b3 I take back with
pawn and this light still stuck kind of
you might play b5 here
you
that's good he's thinking
as it splits take
Oh
like is nice gonna get stuck
you
goes for the counter-attack I could take
on a seven maybe
but I can just move back so similar
yesterday 93 or up d2 or TX and rook d1
he just gives up his night okay
please fighting
you
here
and then trade rooks
time
three
in more rooks
okay IB click or 33 points I'm in 16
place
first place has 48 points a 1900 wait
what
I think a couple of weeks ago there is a
player like in top three who got banned
for cheating I wonder if this could be
another case but I don't know um I know
sometimes cheating could be an issue
with these tournaments now we have a
line which okay this is a great line for
black
hi mama have gone wrong for whites
I like showing students this variation
it's just such a simple line to play
against open Sicilian if they fall into
it
and actually if white plays the right
move here it's not a huge advantage yet
Knight takes c6 is the right move and
Bishop d2
it's only slightly better for lack I
guess bishop
Bishop e7 here probably put the bishop
on f6
I should maybe
liber8 is slightly better for black
because of the kingside majority my
black has potential to create a pass
around a king side or attack on the
Kings side and white doesn't have the
same luxuries on the Queen side
Queen d5 is that a blender or a good
move 25 bishop efore Queens 82 take
might be an exchange sack
willing to go for
oh actually it's not it's a key exchange
because I've Bishop a six hitting the
rook I think
complicated I'm making him think that's
good
there should be 4 is interesting
page of a6 is work to you
okay so emits a g6
mmm
or to move the Queen I don't want to
move the Queen to c5 you don't have too
many squares here
Quincy
[Music]
looks weird but sure
Bishop a6
upon
you
you
see three
you
rook b3 I kind of forgot about
to play 25
you
41 minutes left
lots of headway to make up
25 I guess
this is a tricky position you might go
for like Bishop d6 Bishop before
six I'm okay
he's hitting this in this
you
he takes on c6i Roxy it
I win the c4 pawn
you
expecting rugby 7 here
or that
click on c2
oh he wants to take on d4 and then play
Queen f6 it's kind of scary
let's just be safe
you
you
I would still argue black slightly
better the pawns are weak
upon
it might be
you
I'm winning this pawn okay and maybe
another pawn f2 and a2 are attached and
he's flagging okay
ooh made into
Oh next game so I got four points for
winning that game I guess
keep it up
packers back
Sicilian
you
we'll play this slide maybe he'll go
into the same variation Bishop III the
best move here is Knight d5 he plays
this okay
this is also playable
some sort of like time on of type thing
you
a typical plan here is like 95 94
- can't be a good move
it does leave my Bishop may be a bit
misplaced but
if we drop back to the e7 our night C
for MIG for our ideas
to do
move this Knight to g4
I mean at some point he'll probably play
h3 I have to go back
that's life
I'm still happy with the position
complete development with b5 and Bishop
e7 8 in this case b6
high-pressure have some Hedgehog
deformation
efore is kind of a long-term targets
which he just forgot about that's nice
you
you
take take take take take that's okay
I like Messi when I know what's going on
I don't like messy when I don't don't
know what's going on
I think he has to faking JG - then I can
throw in Queen take d7 so I calculated
this and I just assume I'm attacking the
Queen in the end
and I'll be a v6 change in couple pawns
maybe
you
you
by the way thank you everyone who is
watching and who's uh who's followed I
haven't really paid attention to much I
do have stream labs open I had it open
maybe I can go back the dashboard okay
so he's continuing I'm just up the
exchange into ponds
okay play b5
okay who do I have to think
UH one of Brevik spen pals thanks for
the follow
actually let me focus on this game first
a five maybe
rafi space ninja thanks for the follow
my ho tada thanks for the follow okay
that's enough thank-yous for now let's
finish this game off I'll put the rook
on c8
and kill him quickly
okay next game I have a streak a
four-game streak
I have 41 points I'm in 10th place
George Meyer in first place why beat
earlier he came I guess he came back
playing another lower rated player I
know when quickly here
um time out of line
with Bishop b4 okay so we've had maybe
three similar openings in a row
Hopa should be for stuff
let's play B five
ventral 95 ideas
I'd be similar to last game 9594
I can the sky these people play passive
playing passive moves today a bishop u7
again
should be seven very similar to last
game I want to play d5 I break things
open
you
oh we can max out at four points okay
I'm scrolled up in the chat I see the
okay thank you chess comm Simon I don't
know if you're still here thanks for
explaining the scoring system
so because I'm on the street I can get
four points for each win good to know
also winning upon here
ships attacked and pawns attacks
Ahn's attach three times
a click that
oh maybe I don't run upon
[Music]
but I like my LightSquared bishop
let's bring the rook soon
this diagonal should give him some some
long-term problems I would hope
you
if we can trade like these notes
you
you
I'm in 12th place with 41 points
scheme I'll move up in a tie for eighth
place let's take that pawn do this
you
this apply pressure
the attackers on d4
I'm expecting 9 f3 yeah
maybe I can play this no I okay c5s
attacked I can take
and maybe play my Chi for
why not
you
you
you
have to bring this other rook in or I
just have to flag him
maybe I'll play moves that will try and
make him think the most
can 93
play quick
you
this is just about over
[Music]
you
okay next game I'm in eighth place right
above John Ludwig hammer right below
Creek or first place I can't see the
score of 50 something points ie for this
game I try and make a run for it
g6 let's play h4
then each five
quick attack
I'll go for this
somewhat unusual line but looks fun
a for stopping b5
this
interesting
might as well take maybe 9 f4
maybe not
I like this pawn tension because black
never wants to take I always have ideas
of taking and also playing each six also
playing 95 maybe 96
winning the exchange okay he resigns
that's what I need
I just need quick games I have a streak
of six points I'm in fifth place seems
like a few minutes ago I was like in
30th place we'll play another efore game
and playing rocky tall another Knight c3
Sicilian grand priests is filling this
time
I'm let's out the opening
it's relatively quickly
always clicking each one
here what to do maybe Queen let's play
Queen g3 Queen h3 cool idea
and then eventually s5
trade
I want to attack let's play f5
maybe g4g five ideas snack at the bishop
traps
we got three rub g3 ideas too
let's just start with or with this
immediate threat of g5 and then maybe f6
even
that's a decent move
the Queen each five kinds of prepare sg5
thrusts
then I can't play Queen h4 okay we I
guess we repeats
though for this manoeuvre Knight to f3
I'm okay with the bishop trade I just
want to play g5 ASAP let's play this
move e5 is coming he's not stopping it
h6 doesn't stop it because H pawn is
pinned I also have nine h4 ideas
9h for ounce by g5
any crushing blow baby now this is my G
sixes mates
he's gonna probably play 97 but then I
still play 96 and it's over and maybe
could pre move my g6
um okay oh no it's not over icons pinned
all those careless
I completely forgot the pawn his pins I
was really careless
okay now I have to fight it should have
been another quick win
you
or down the piece the tax is still there
it's just not as strong because I lost a
piece for no reason
[Music]
interesting move because I have to play
f6
preventing Queen age three
they use H files on
like King King g1 King F to rook h1 is
some some kind of plan
or maybe rook f1 or f2
ideas
h4
I take
I've some funny plan oh it doesn't work
though Oh Kim Ji Won was a terrible move
actually maybe it's still okay I've
queen h1 ideas
do this
eh one but if h4 I would have played
Queen h1
scary he might want a sack on each uncie
- at some point
I want a sack on each five at some
points
I might play rook gh3 it looks reckless
but
annoying for him
if you get Solara in time I'll probably
play rock gh3
but next few moves I'll probably play
like kini won in d1
oh he wants to win a for okay let's go
for this
I'm meeting him take take take take
meets
I'm not meeting him what am I seeing
today at least I have g6 and it's still
scary for him
I'm completely blind today okay this is
this is not yet meat
maybe as this is just too much just for
me
should be winning though
pretty messy game
and throwing
Oh check and play g7
ooh chef on be three controls GE that
was sneaky
time to - dirty flag
you
okay I flagged him I have 53 points I'm
in fourth place there's money on the
line us guys playing b3 let's play a
whatever this is t4
um let's play six we'll play like some
reversed whatever
actually don't know what this is guess I
can take
[Music]
hmm
should be seven I guess
looks somewhat playable because Bishop
before happens you might be in some
trouble here gets to play that move I
can take and play Queen here
you
this looks very troublesome oh he can't
talk he has rook c1 here and he survives
but we can trade trade to this ending
late middle game type thing or he can't
castle
maybe like d6 and
see what he does
so you can't develop as Bishop he might
play Queens III but that I play Queen g5
two minutes left
57 points so I have to break into I have
to pass bloodstream I don't know how to
tell if like the person's on a streak or
not let's do this
maybe this
eat to play f6 safe move
building the Queen and then I have like
ripped g1 Queen h4 he'll play rook g3
it's actually sort of sharp
rook g3
I'm still a recursive
some points
up a pond under a little bit of pressure
doesn't look too bad
greedy I can maybe take on each - I
should probably complete developments
Bishop d7 rookie eights things are
defended
five
allowing any Bishop c4 stuff
and maybe this move
now the plan is Bishop e6
there should be six and rook TA and then
maybe you tried T for e for breaks look
nice
and he's thinking that's good
Virg Meyer has 60 something points
kind of annoying like they they should
reduce the clutter here you don't need
the flag of the player
DeForest coming
or
not calculating just judging my
decisions based on principles
I can take with two row
things going to be open at Bishop f5
here
mmm King see - you can see - I have rook
c4 that's a nice move
and so he plays that he wants to take on
g7 picking up it
trying to figure out the threats
take like a
then take enough to
looks good enough winning a rook
you
my play Queen III
we need three of a thinking genes
okay this is over I'll have time for a
few more games
game 57 points still in fourth place I
think I'm tied with bloodstream I think
that looks like a 57
taking longer than normal okay playing
elves 21 we have an English I'll play
more aggressively than normal
ng3
hmm I could play a reverse Grand Prix
yeah let's play rivers Grand Prix
if you play z3d 5's a cool move
keyline
I think d3 is only good move here plays
92 neglecting my ideas and now 94 this
looks fun
whose f2 can't really be defended this
is one of the very first lines I learned
against English well about line if
you're looking for something simple
mmm I take the
I've night before though
this just looks bad for him because
Queens almost trapped is to play queen
bee - I don't know if I want to take the
rook I think I'll probably play Knight
fd3 and then like Bishop c5 or Bishop d6
while he's so brave knight c2
I see two
attacking the Queen twice also attacking
the rook if Queen a4f is a d7 his queen
us almost no squares except that one
which I kind of forgot about
I could take I can't take the bishop
efore
wait a minute
you
- here
you
I guess I play you for I give him some
squares but I solidify in regard he
might sack on you for I don't think
that's great for him though
such a tease southern no I just want a
castle good trade nights I guess
goodnight sand castle
position
asacs coming
pp 5v5 when something
I would be too
these resign the Queen strapped yes okay
he resigns I'm I've won nine games in a
row I'm in third place 61 points
well last samurai has 63 something
points I'm playing another 1700
let's win quickly b6 let's play this
whatever this is I'm gonna play h4 weird
move but he's trying to play a hippo so
I want to kill him
h h4 h5 is one of the best ways to
disrupt the hippo as far as I know let's
play d4 here
if G 495 mmm okay he's doing stuff let's
play for corrupt him on the queenside -
that's kind of annoying play Bishop d3
can trade then I'll play Bishop a3
you might Castle
okay let's play a five this looks very
very fun then a six kick is Bishop
now his bishops dead mice position I
just want to win quickly okay he castles
that's a good sign I'll play I'll go for
this my Chi for fan well I can take
take and play Queen b6 maybe
nights
I mean this is winning it's just about
winning quickly
keeping the streak yeah I can't take the
night right away because rookie Yates
maybe I just Castle queenside
and as positions falling apart
the Queen f6 could be annoying because
you might play that on for a while
have sex I might what is that that's a
move I guess my Queens are tats and play
this
now let's not risk it let's play Queen
d5 attack the rook
take with the rook
and maybe rook f3
I've probably not played the most
accurately but I just want to attack
this King I'm expecting 97 then Queenie
6
Queen d7 probably a better move
hmm do this
you
not sure what the threat is
pick
like queen bee No so I have to we need
for rookie and I think the queen is
trapped
good news is if he plays if he ever
plays d5 ACCA's b5 square for the night
also hangs exchange
I work strapped what okay I guess I have
to take
to h6
wait this is bad I better not lose this
material is such a good opening to
the cost of playing quickly trying to
win
keep my composure
it's like we're now seven I will go into
this game type thing putting some pawns
keeping the time advantage
place that says 63
you
in d2 King III hold on to the pond
and then f3 old hunter the night
everything's defended I'm I'm gonna win
this game by flagging him but that's
life a th six
here
toy around with rook t1
do you one
we get some
one kind of mates
maybe not
I see three those Kings fell off so hope
there's some mating ideas
do this with check
this is a fork
I wanna keep my nights
you
oh that was a terrible move
did that I'm just trying to flag him
okay X gained 65 points still in third
place
playing Stewie Griffin this is a decent
player
ready it whatever this is
Bishop f5 each six
maybe bring the night to the b6 and c4
like a decent plan
looks a bit weakening I can play 85
bishop on each seven and another bishop
on b4
and complain
maybe 97
eight nights
you
before
pick
d for
what's going on here but I think he has
problems
I think he has major problems actually I
just went at peace or the exchange yeah
let's take and then see five
maybe
just have to keep my composure
maybe he'll resign as it's just a bad
position maybe not
take the rook or is a target
fancy a
maybe neither six coming I have to watch
out for that move but I can take care
rights reap on
our targeted
the Queenie seven
you
is trying to keep it smooth
I pull up as the night doesn't have like
any good squares he might play Knight c1
but then rookie one
can take simplify
for this
f2 is weak
and it's maybe he'll play a Bishop III
but then rook to e3
okay good game um you know weights
okay good next game Sarika 11 I'm
playing George minor again let's try and
beat him twice in a row
oh he has 70 points - so this is a
really important game I could overtake
him for first maybe oh no he's in
seconds someone pass him maybe someone
passed him
we're playing some whatever this is I
don't want to go into theory against him
I guess I have to
[Music]
Tribble he probably knows what he's
doing
I should have played c6 online and play
c6
okay um what to do bishop
a six here in the 97 96
you
be better for whites
maybe I can equalize someday with c5 try
c5 right now
maybe six
this is scary
94 comes with ambition t4
actually
- because it's somewhat imbalance he's
not getting like the typical positional
Bynes
with rook e8
open file
Brookes have smiles on open files now
we'll play Bishop D for ideas of Queen
f6
I mean Queen f6 could run into Knight e4
but that's life
I might have three good move
maybe Queen f6 anyway
I don't want to give him a bishop here
but
and then the C file could open and rook
c8 happens he plays another good move
but queen g6
take-take-take I lose upon
you
what else to do
that's the only move right only move and
I hurts
losing a pond
wanted and he is a bishop pair
you
[ __ ]
you
you
this is just an easy win at his level
I'll resign I want time for one more
game how do I resign resign okay next
game now is unfortunate
on 3rd place
um
in order for this game to finish I need
to not use more than a minute on the
clock that's how it works
I'll play relatively quickly we're going
into some online where White has a lot
of attacking potential
always play King b1 always play h4 okay
a chief or Bishop g5
f6 is considering f6 clicking b1
I feel like the Queen belongs on e to
and not d to the poor decision earlier
now the G file is open
mm yeah let's just put all the pieces on
the kingside probably go for H 5 H 6
eventually
and take the pond with the Queen on c3
there's a funny mate if he plays
either I think they can play queen take
g7
not meats but it's just a nice sign
we're going into some endgame
okay
I need the tournament timer to always be
more than his timer but basically I have
40 seconds talking this uh he didn't
blunder there I wish he did
[Music]
what to do maybe Bishop efore buying a
lot of pressure
I still in third place is George Mayer
streaming bigger question
in his Last Samurai streaming
and I might be guaranteed more money
okay let's take and we'll play this rook
ending out
uh I miscalculated his plans are so weak
or gauge for very soon
my pawns are weak too but his palms
should be weaker
you
I'll play rookie 593
things defended maybe I'll play out for
even a for rookie for f3
now I playoff for
I'll take on d4 with the king my pawns
are defended
a cap remove this
oh let's get the past c-pawn
four and then rock age three activate
the rook
but he didn't play rook c5 there
a seven is a target also g6 is a targets
the rook even more
this is winning right I have two passers
which is kind of sad
wait a minute
what's going on here
is up
I mess this up
sad
this is so so sad
- endgame - I'm gonna finish in fourth
place
he said
actually if even if I all winning
position I know if the tournament would
end oh and the gang got aborted because
oh the game was aborted so that didn't
count for rating I guess that's a good
thing I finished in fourth place I lost
to George Mayer and then I was losing
against this guy
what a cool end game though look at that
what did I do wrong oh I had to play
King f3 first yeah King F 3 and then
King G 3
it's really instructive though because
King f3 looks like Azari losing after f5
I think I think it's losing here this is
very instructive
[Music]
illustrate Slyke two very very
interesting Keene plant and game ideas
first idea of being the concept of the
barricade or the double pawns are
actually very effective in blocking out
the king which results in like all these
subs long positions my opponent f2 is
such a unfortunately play spawn then the
second idea is the fact that pawns that
are spaced was this three files of parts
or with a to file gap they can be
controlled by the king so there's no way
to like to actually promote a pawn here
without losing both of them because if
here here
you're here and now the king is always
within range of both pawns
so I played a for a waiting move I don't
think HP makes any difference because he
plays 84
and then yeah just King d6 and
it's just looks long for for white even
if it wasn't so long as its lacks move I
mean he's just gonna win the pawns
very instructive example what's wrong
with f6 followed by c5 so if I play f6
here you can play in g6 you're fake
you're here and he catches upon
Oh though f6 in this position wait f6
here t5 you're here
oh I missed a win I could have played f6
that's so simple
I guess the pawns are far enough or his
King is far away enough
f6 here and then c5
your your fake yeah I guess uh the pause
would need to be shifted down a ring for
the King to catch them and at least in
this situation yeah
good a good point Daniel Moreno I was
still winning
interesting well interesting tournaments
um I don't know if I want money because
I have no idea if the other players were
streaming I finished in fourth place uh
hopefully I get to be nominated for some
sort of Twitter poll again I've been
nominated the other two times I played
last time I lost to John Logue Luke
hammer if if we're in the same poll
again I'm gonna treat it a lot more
competitively and try and get revenge
for him getting more votes in me last
time
other than that I finished ahead of I
finish ahead of hammer this time
[Music]
I beat George Meyer earlier in the event
but then he beat me and then good job
Last Samurai
I think I played once only once in one
um yeah thanks everyone for watching of
I'll feel like ending it but I think
I'll end it here I might be back later
um
[Music]
yeah actually I might be back later I
was about to say I'll probably be back
later but I have a lot of work to do
just got back from st. Louis yesterday
it's been a long long past week like
very little sleep and a lot of catching
up to do so if I'm back later I might do
a quick stream on me chest but for now
I'm ending it I'm just looking for
someone to raid I'll see who's streaming
in crush your streaming let's go to
twitch who can we raid
which dot TV
I'm gonna search for chess
okay I'm just gonna expand this a little
bit search for chess
well chess stream is actually happening
I guess there's Simon Williams is hammer
[Music]
let's stream or let's try and raid
someone who's a bit less
less popular let's raid JJ
if you guys don't know JJ I hope he's
not ending it
have to raid him before this ends no
he's ending the stream no
before it ends okay
so we're rating the sky
this and then where's my chats this is
my checks so raid HHS
okay I'm stopping streaming bye everyone